黒い数がラーメン書使うやつレビューした止まったんですけど
気づけましたセンター試験なんでそれはちょっと
語りながら片手曲でセスがあるねえ
それならちょっと
明日の人立つ応援みたいな感じにしたいと思います
とりあえず今まで勉強頑張った人たちお疲れ様でした
ず限制も導入生の方も
6すごい
本当に頑張った人はすごい頑張ったと思いますもう
出れば防振で勉強みたいな感じだったと思うんで
まあ明日は自らを出す切って来てください
うん
あ僕なぁ
話になるんですけど
曲に入る前にセンターわけなんですけど
なんか直前なもし
かなぁ
直前度も助け怖かったんですけど前端すけんだよ
150店当日
落ちちゃって
それも
繋がったんですよね
二税大学行きたい大学にも行けなくなったんですけど
まぁなんとさーん
ありまして
蔓の学びたいことが学べる大学に入れました
なんで船体色はもうず
思ってにいい
いかなかったとしてもあまり深く考えないでください
なるようになります
センター試験必要な大学には行けなくなっちゃうかもしれないんですけど
第二ですねー
学校には行けなくなったかもしれないんですけど
黒い
それ以外の大学に行けばいいんですそこで最古の学べば
人はわー
なりたい自分になれると思うんだよ
頑張ってください
好きだしたーー
センター試験
頑張ってください
付け終わったらもう僕みたいに大学で馬鹿なことしてもいいし何してもいいと思うんだ
よ
もう一息ですん
受験生の方
まあ失敗してもいいですよ
園田なったっていうことが大事なんで
お願いします
ラーメン食べます
ゆあされたんですけど数学1 a とか鈍いする人
刷新の最初は通学市から始まったり見えてから始まったりするんで
ちゃんとあの裏の1 ab らとから始めてください
じゃん